self-proclaimed racist yes look at that
sniff that up I ain't going nowhere you
have my address you know where I'm at
come get me did you have a strap just
now
Tate's back he took a nap after his
final speech next day he's on Fox News
and now he's on Rumble with an emergency
meeting the Matrix attacks he goes app
get off your phone dude I am ordering
pizza again let me eat all right a slave
driver we gotta we gotta film for them
I'm ready I'm ready just don't it don't
talk to me like that he goes nuts on
this pretty cool I'm glad he's on Rumble
now he he's it's like Tate times when
did this get posted back go back for a
second this is this is yesterday this is
brand spanking new all right well let's
get right in everybody gets a rumble and
let's support everything The Matrix is
attacking this stream as we speak the
Matrix is afraid Tristan they fired
their biggest weapon at us they looked
at us and thought they have too much
power too much influence let's him with
the most powerful weapon we have let's
cancel them let's close all their
accounts let's make them banish let's
let's destroy their influence that's the
biggest bullet they have imagine
shooting a man with your last bullet and
he stands there
unfazed do I look cancel it 70
000 people watching us I don't feel
canceled do you feel canceled well isn't
that triple the number of our largest
ever stream up until this point with
emergency meeting live how crazy he's
just gonna explode they get six figures
on a brand new platform without even
having platforms to promote it on it's
just their minions promoting it that's
like there's never been a following like
this in the history of anything this is
this is absurd it's insane
they have made martyrs of us and let me
tell you something let me tell you the
mistakes today
the only time in human history were the
betas of Earth had power over the alphas
before this they had no power but now
they have a little bit of power they can
cancel you that's what they can do they
can come along and cancel you and
everyone they've canceled so far ended
up canceled so they thought they could
cancel the top G it's the weapon that
always works they fired the bullet that
never fails it bounced off of my skin
and here I am I still emerge more
powerful than ever before there is a
large contingent of the population
there's a large contingent of men out
there who don't want to wear makeup who
don't want to be girls who don't want to
be told they're toxic because they want
to go to the gym who want to drive nice
cars who want to have money who want to
have hot chicks and there's nothing
wrong with us we are not evil we are not
bad we're not misogynistic we're not out
to hurt anybody let me tell you one more
thing when bad things happen they call
men like us the feminists who hate us
and call us toxic to sex can they have
trouble they'll call a police officer do
you think they want a feminist male to
turn up or a man like me and you they
need us and they use us but the second
we have an opinion
and talk about the things that we talk
about explain our points of view they
want to cancel us they don't want us to
speak they just want us to defend them
build the railroads build the roads be
the workhorses be the slaves and they
think we're not allowed on a point of
view well they made a [ __ ] mistake
because I like every great leader
throughout history charge first before
my army cavalry charge at the enemy you
can cancel me I'm about to pave the road
for every other man out here with an
opinion who's gonna get canceled I'll
show you where to [ __ ] go
bro let's get ready to rumble bro I
don't think he knows no let's go [ __ ]
cancel culture that's hype I don't think
he knows how many women are behind him
also he does not know well he knows like
he has his girls
just like this though and
are also
in fact follow us on Rumble I'll drop
the link in the description
uncensored Sunny fast and Mom gentlemen
listening and ladies
we have been producing content on the
internet once I hate to interrupt you I
hate to interrupt you only sexy ladies
watch us only sexy ladies gentlemen and
sexy ladies
say that say whatever we want anymore
now I and my brother have been providing
you they're even happier now who like
they literally took their RPG the the
elites they're like this is gonna get
him this is this is it boom
here he is smiling with his with his
girls his Jets say whatever the [ __ ] I
want now well until app the app store
takes down Rumble but that's like whole
that's that's the last last straw that's
like insane do you think that they would
do that people would follow them to the
doctor they've done it before they've
done it before with parlor people would
follow them to the dark web you know I
don't know if they would do that again I
wonder you think that they would they
would shut them off on what do you guys
think they've done it before yeah I know
they have it's content advice older
brotherly advice
life-changing tips hacks
for the last seven years we've let you
look into the depth of our souls we've
told you how to live life lives worth
living and we've never asked you for a
single thing in return
now I'm calling in the favor A
revolution is nothing but a group of
like-minded men together aiming their
Force towards the same goal and we are
now the revolution we are that group of
like-minded men and sexy ladies what I
need from you is to press record on this
stream it might cut out any second as
good and solid as Rumble is we are being
attacked from all angles by big Tech I
need you to record this stream I need
you you to record my words I need you to
spread this message everywhere
throughout the Matrix like agent Smith
multiplying through the program I need
you on Instagram I need you on YouTube I
need you on Facebook I need you we got
you Tristan you better invite us to that
sneaker one mill party that'd be dope
yeah I already told snico I'd chaperone
the party if he needs me to come on
Twitter
that this is what happens when you try
to cancel real men for everybody out
there who's on YouTube cool keep using
it but build your Rumble platform build
your platforms over here because this is
the place where you are safe this is the
place where you are secure start putting
money in the bank in terms of your
followers and your subscribers right
here I literally said when people would
DM me asking like what's the solution
like what's with what everything's going
on what are your thoughts I'm like we
need to we need to decentralized social
media platform and I thought phase two
would be them starting their own
platform but them just coming on to
rumble which seems decentralized and you
can say whatever you want it's pretty
amazing so my my solution that I had in
mind is just coming out so that's pretty
I'd like to point out again that I've
been telling you about Rumble and you've
been ignoring me yeah well yeah no
because the moment
believe me they're gonna ask you your
mom tells you a social media platform
she's like it's for it's a conservative
news platform you're like all right Mom
and you're right I'll give it to you do
many of the people watching our videos
not say that I am based does that Mom is
based that right but you're still my mom
you know I see your opinions as my mom
opinions not like based mama like my
whatever let's keep going wake up wait
I'm stuck in The Matrix just like they
tried to ax us
one of my favorite Bible verses that I'm
gonna read to all of you content
creators out there and everyone trying
to build your channels when I say switch
to rumble let me hit you with Matthew 7
24-7
everyone who hears these words of mine
and does them will be like a wise man
who built his house on the rock and the
rain fell and the floods came and the
winds blew and beat on that house but it
did not fall because it had been founded
on the Rock and everyone who hears these
words of mine and does not do them will
be like the foolish man who built his
house on the sand and the rain fell and
the floods came and the wind blew and
beat against the house and it fell and a
great fall it was start today move to
rumble move your social medias together
let's get on these apps that are run by
real men who want to hear discourse he
just legit flat out compared himself to
the Lord Jesus Christ like he flat out
said here's from here's what Matt
Matthew quoting Jesus and he prepared
and he made a direct comparison they're
the biggest titles although from a from
a non-spiritual standpoint this is
what's happening they tried to destroy
Jesus they made him from the biggest
thing since sliced bread throughout
history his his story spread around the
world at that point from that point on
and that's what they're doing here they
just thought that YouTube is like
Pontius Pilate
yeah I didn't pay attention in school
but well oh now all of a sudden the
Bible's interesting okay go ahead and
hit go yeah not one Mr whatever his face
I don't even remember that guy's name
those opinions different people's points
of view and this is the future of the
internet and all of you I need you to
help me out right now this is what we
need to do this is now the revolution it
absolutely is like like you said we're
calling in the troops gentlemen if
you're watching this gentlemen and sexy
ladies I'm gonna give you all a 15
second break I want I'm gonna play a
video now and I want all of you to make
an Instagram story for this video do an
Instagram story at tagrumble.com take
speech because the Matrix hates me the
Matrix they've sat around the table
they're probably watching this right now
head execs hello meta hello guys hello
YouTube I didn't want to be canceled I
was on your side I wanted to speak for
men's issues I thought it was a place
for open discourse I thought I was
allowed to have an opinion and we could
make the world a better place I'm not an
extremist I love women I protect women
and any woman who's around me feel safe
I thought we could sit around and talk
but no you decided my opinion isn't
worth anything you decided all the
millions of men who think like me are
worth [ __ ] nothing you decided that I
didn't want this war you [ __ ] did and
then you told me that I'm not allowed on
your platforms and you told me that I'm
not allowed anywhere well that's fine
because I have soldiers and we're going
to penetrate The Matrix I'm gonna play a
video and I want everyone to make an
Instagram let's put it all over
[ __ ] Instagram [ __ ] you Matrix
God
I have my address you know where I'm at
come get me
did he have a strap just now I believe
so yes oh yeah
I love how he's in this podcast studio
called [ __ ] cut me yeah he's just
pulling out they probably sat there and
they were like okay what can we they're
like bringing the guns bringing the sexy
ladies like what else can we talk about
to just piss these people off this is
the [ __ ] funniest thing ever really
screaming Fu to The Matrix now or I just
wish that that we had this point of view
the camera we could see this camera that
they're talking into I wish they would
switch up cameras you know what I mean
instead of us watching it from the side
yeah I mean I guess we do that too we
look into a screen well they're we're
not looking into a camera I know but
he's he is his message we're talking to
each other and watching something we're
doing that there's a reason for that
they are talking to the world Fu Matrix
this not you like I want to see I want
to see it it's too far this is this is
this is the greatest emergency meeting
yeah let's keep going yeah this is
fantastic
well top G he has a lot of influence and
he's helping men with men's issues but
we don't care about men's issues and we
don't care about free speech and we
don't care about anything that people go
through so we're just going to cancel
him and then instead we're going to feed
them uh a YouTube timeline where they
can watch men try different makeup on
and hopefully they'll decide to watch
one of them instead they hope you're
just gonna forget about top G you're
going to forget about all the lessons
you're going to forget about the
lifestyle I purport you're gonna forget
about all the things I can teach you and
instead you're just going to run away
and do something else oh let's just
delete Andrew and maybe they'll watch
about makeup and maybe they'll just go
do that look over here guys look over
here they try and distract you with some
shiny toys ice bucket challenge uh
everyone do water challenges and pour
ice on your head they think you're dumb
they think you're stupid but you are not
stupid that's why you are here and you
need to show them that you're not stupid
because you have a memory and just
because they've deleted me doesn't mean
you don't remember who I am and what I
teach and why you need to be part of
this movement and that's why you're
going to come with us to rumble this is
the first time ever that the social
media's primary weapon the beta males
primary every weapon of canceling is
going to fail and they're going to sit
around having panicked meetings if
they're not already doing it watching
this stream thinking [ __ ] we should have
kept them on our platforms because we
kept them on our platforms we could have
at least to some degree created his
content we could have come to him and
said you know what Andrew very important
discussion very important thing but you
need to change the way you say this etc
etc and I'm a reasonable man I would
have spoke to him okay ass panel in this
comp in all these companies came
together and said we have to get rid of
them and that's what happens when you
let the inmates run the Asylum it's a
goddamn business and they let all the
little woke lunatics in the company
create policy mom you think it's the
little woke idiots in the company that
decided this or it's the elites I don't
even think it's it runs that deep
because I think a lot of the people in
the companies think that what they're
doing is wrong you don't think that
these people that work for these
companies believe in free speech or do
you think a lot of them
not cases let's talk about Disney for a
second so it's the woke there's there's
this division that is there specifically
leader to make Disney more work and they
because the company is so afraid of the
mob that they are listening to these
people and what they're doing is
alienating all the rest of us who don't
want all this [ __ ] in our children's
programming that we don't need to talk
about sex to little kids we don't need
to focus on Race because little kids
don't see race they see nice or not nice
fun or not fun and so what they've done
now is they've created a power nightmare
for themselves where a lot of people are
just like screw you I don't need Disney
I have plenty of entertainment for my
kids there's so many other options they
used to have the market corner they
don't anymore so what I think here is
happening is now somebody like the guy
that used to run Twitter he was super
woke and he did play a big part in it
but a lot of this is these departments
that are coming in and you've got these
young people in this Tech space who are
all so woke and so offended by
everything and everything is a song and
dance and they are letting them run the
show ultimately instead of saying we're
in charge we're making decisions based
on business period and what works and
they're not doing that so maybe it's a
combination but it's [ __ ] so they
are just talking about now they are now
they have no control whatsoever over me
how did we let this get this back now
I'm completely an outlaw a renegade the
a team that's what they've done and they
think that you're gonna forget but
you're not gonna forget and that's why
we're gonna permeate The Matrix do not
fall for the Trap the Trap that they've
laid for you is that you are stupid and
if you're not a stupid person ain't
gonna work and gentlemen don't forget
who you are it's not about forgetting
about the talus man it's not about
forgetting about top G Andrew Tate don't
forget who you are if you're on if you
find yourself one day on YouTube
scrolling alone with the sun on your
face jerking off to stupid videos
what's the line there was a line there I
was about to nail the Gladiator line
listen you have become a dork
do not do that don't forget who you are
everything that we've tried to teach you
is against that kind of behavior if you
find yourself scrolling the next YouTube
challenge and it's people throwing ice
water on each other or jumping into
pools or rolling around in the mud and
you've forgotten to watch the people who
are important the people who teach you
lessons in life and I'm just I'm not
just talking about me they want you
addicted to porn they want you they want
you like hooked onto this stuff just a
sleeve to your phone like on Tick Tock
if you scroll all it is is booty cheeks
if you go on Twitch a girl literally had
sex on a twitch live stream and she got
a one week ban and people who speak just
like like like these guys they get
infinite bands for not even breaking any
rules it's crazy and then you go on
Twitch and there's a lady who is butt
naked with just paint over her who has
and she's getting like shown out there
they literally want these kids from
their little just scrolling on Twitch to
find video games to be addicted to this
stuff in week Wilds it's horrible do not
do that don't forget who you are
everything that we've tried to teach you
is against that kind of behavior here if
you find yourself scrolling the next
YouTube challenge and it's people
throwing ice water on each other or
jumping into pools or rolling around in
the mud and you've forgotten to watch
the people who are important the people
who teach you lessons in life and I'm
just I'm not just talking I was gonna
say as much as people like to [ __ ] on me
and say like oh this kid he's being too
much like he likes the Tates a lot and
he's trying to be like them it's like
these are like the main the main guys
you look up to and then there's someone
like if you're 18 or 19 you can look at
someone like me who's actually done this
and generated millions of dollars and be
like yeah that's like it's more of a
realistic comparison to my like that I
can compare myself to is someone my age
or a little bit older than me that's
done this stuff and is helping to teach
people with it too rather than just
these guys because it is a little
intimidating looking at someone like
this who's done so much and it feels
unrealistic people can talk themselves
out of [ __ ] which is also like I could
never be also why we got to listen to
them you know because as soon as that
voice comes in your mind and it starts
talking you out of this [ __ ] is when
you've got to kill it and go with the
good voice so taking this stuff in
constantly but I agree with you like
coming to somebody that's relatable
that's also got the same messages you
know is is a great thing and then you
know moving you just keep moving forward
moving forward and as you grow and you
you get I have so much room to grow I
literally just turned 19. like I'm
literally at like one percent of of the
bond you know what I mean I haven't done
[ __ ] that's a long way to go I get a lot
of like really nice DMS and saying like
people like I motivate people and stuff
like that which is great but like I
still have so much to do you know and so
much to improve as a person and that's
also a reason why I like watching their
videos they're some of the smartest
people at the top and with a platform I
just love listening to them very
motivational and stuff what about me I'm
talking about the other people who are
going to move over to rumble I'm talking
about fresh and fair I want to see their
channel so I want to see sneako over
here I want to see all the boys building
up their channels here because I'm
telling you the moment we're building up
our head above the line we're almost on
Rumble they're gonna whip you back in
the line and if they can't they're gonna
cut your head off so I want to see all
my boys here everybody everybody it's
not just about us
platforms and Tristan's right if you
ever find yourself on their platform
just scrolling up and down mindlessly
you are literally just scrolling up and
down propaganda waiting for some of it
to bite and control your mind don't fall
for it you don't need to do that you
need to be here this is where you belong
we have a few super chats I want to talk
about quickly before we move on with the
show so talk about some super chats but
I want you to all to understand
something one more thing that's really
really important I am an extremely
intelligent man
I've been underestimated most of my life
they underestimated me when they banned
me and they think I don't know how these
things work what's actually more
interesting is all these Lefty social
media companies they think that everyone
who works for them agrees with their
censorship
but it's not true yeah there are some
people who work for these talk about to
understand they're out of control
so I have a lot of information I know
how things work right let's just put it
that way I was just going to say because
I was talking about the Disney thing and
there's this whole other contention of
Disney employees that are starting to
little by little open their mouths they
don't want to because they're afraid to
lose their jobs not crazy but some of
them are like I'm putting my job on the
line because I just want you to know
that we're all not [ __ ] nuts yeah
we're all not into this [ __ ]
they are monitoring both meta Facebook
and Instagram and YouTube are monitoring
in real time everything I do they're
watching this stream they're monitoring
all the public feedback they're trying
to work out if they made the right
decision or made a mistake actually
today a poll appeared to one of my
friends Instagrams a random poll he
never had an Instagram poll before that
popped up saying ever ever hey what do
you think about our censorship policies
and ask them a bunch of questions about
censorship to see if they censor too
much they are panicking because they
have noticed that everybody loves me and
nobody hates me and what they tried to
do is they got the media machine to lie
about me and say that I'm a danger to
women and I'm a horrible person and they
told a bunch of lies and only 10 of
idiots believed it 90 of people know
it's a lie and all they've done is
destroyed their own credibility destroy
their own trust nobody believes the lies
they're telling what about their fact
Checkers remember all their fact
Checkers and how we were supposed to
trust them and they were wrong about
[ __ ] almost everything and here they
are again yeah that but those fact
Checkers only work on social media
things when when it's uh it's a [ __ ]
narrative they're trying to push on you
but when they want Tate to be called a
misogynist they want him to be taken
down and destroyed as a man they don't
they don't fact check those little those
little fake tick tocks and no videos
nope pieces of [ __ ]
every single [ __ ] every single Tick Tock
all of your comments in this live
they're watching this live videos on
YouTube they're trying to delete to
delete all the positive videos about me
on YouTube if you do a video on YouTube
that supports me they delete it if you
do a story on Instagram that supports me
they delete it they're trying to delete
it all because they're watching it going
[ __ ] everyone actually loves him and we
made a mistake we have to change public
opinion they are trying to famuce you
it's a big trick okay silence trick you
for moose you is that an urban
dictionary
is that a real word I don't know I just
know what it kind of means spread some
lies about him being a misogynist press
the [ __ ] button that's what it was
about you're 100 right it was nothing to
do do with misogyny it was nothing to do
with women it was nothing to do with men
and the the issues that we pushed they
talk about protecting women if you're
going to protect women this is the thing
that I've just made a point earlier but
I'll say it again if a woman gets in
trouble they call men like me if
someone's assaulting a woman on the
street you call men like me if someone
if a woman's taken kidnap you call men
like me these male feminists can't
protect women they can't save women they
are just hateful all these people who
have said I'm a misogynist have no
interest in the truth they just want a
reason to hate me because they're
jealous of my Monumental successes and
they're trying to weaponize the idea of
misogyny and protecting women if you
wanted to protect women why don't you go
and get big and strong and get a wife
that you take care of if they really
wanted to protect women they'd breed men
like this and they'd let them say his
they'd let him go off in his hands but
the patriarchy is bad
why don't you donate with money to
women's Charities yes no you don't do
anything you just sit on the internet
sending hate hey hey hey hey these are
sad hateful people I'm gonna talk about
my haters on this show and let me tell
you something that nobody is less safe
around women sorry nobody's a bigger
danger around women than these people
Google these words Google go to Google
to type images and type child
molestation uh suspect rape suspect
scroll through the images and find the
guy who looks like me in his ten
thousand dollar suit yeah find the guy
who's Big and Rich and sexy fine never
it's not these guys it's these little
gremlins nerds that are sitting there
little gremlins going oh nobody is a
bigger danger to women than these people
and they use the mask of I'm women's
Ally I hate people like Andrew Tate
really they're just sad because women
like men like Andrew Tate women like men
like me and they're angry and they're
sad so they pretend to be a woman's Ally
hoping that she'll cry on his shoulder
one day so we can slip something in her
drink these people are [ __ ] animals
all of them absolutely every single five
more Super chats and we did 100 holy
[ __ ] these guys just don't miss they're
on Fire Plus viewers the blood is
pumping the entire war room is here 100
Super Chat from 19. I don't even have
anything to say it's like they're just
speaking my mind for me I absolutely
love it
that's what I'm saying it's really
fascinating though that that the rumor
mill and how absolutely over the past 10
years how [ __ ] crazy it's gotten with
it with the technology and it's it's
similar what they're saying is you know
rumor like labels stick you know when
Junior High somebody could have said
um you know Susie Susie gave the whole
football team BJ's you know meanwhile
Susie's like sitting at home you know
knitting on Friday and Saturday nights
but if somebody says that it is just
then true and it you know Susie doesn't
have any recourse these guys are as they
constantly remind us to have cheese and
they and they're fighting back and they
also have an army behind them of people
that are willing to get online and get
out there and and speak the truth so
it's just fascinating to me though how
it went from something so simple but in
the end all the people that start the
lives from the top journalists in the
world down to the little gremlins in
their basements they're all teenage
girls because I was all teenage Junior
High [ __ ] that went on and this is
just teenage girls on a bigger scale and
they all need to get that through their
heads they're all just a bunch of
[ __ ] weak gossiping teenage little
[ __ ] brats do you think you're right
we haven't grown up yet and Tates and
Tate's Army what what rank are we in in
spreading the truth we're not in his
[ __ ] Army we are in our own Army but
we are allies to his army I was just
making a joke no all right I just want
to be clear yeah we're doing our own
thing in general mother here Tate text
you you got it the [ __ ] video is not
up for the truth they need a mom to say
it yeah we'll get the lottery we'll get
the left length for him that's fine but
you know no oh look at it
it's so funny because every single thing
that they like there's never been a
period in time where every attack they
come at him with there's like
irrefutable defense against it you
racist my dad's black you're you're a
misogynist no one's literally ever said
any a woman I've ever spent time with
has always said good things about me
they always feel safe like every single
thing that they say there's an instant
rebuttal there's nothing else they can
do back to them it's insane I've never
seen anything like this no well you
haven't been paying attention because
this is what's been going on for years
with the with the Average Joe's
everybody's every time somebody doesn't
can't disagrees and they have no actual
facts it's just name-calling yeah name
calling and and so that's what they're
doing to them except you know you can
destroy Joe schmoe easily but you can't
now and Joe Schmo doesn't care anymore
now but now it's great because these
guys are empowering everybody to say up
yours call me a name you want I've said
it before okay I've been called racist
so many times because I'm I lean
conservative even though I'm very
liberal in certain areas and in the
beginning like I said it hurt me and I
was sad and now I'm like you know you're
fine I'm racist up yours go carry on
[ __ ] self-proclaimed racist yes look
at that snip that up
[Music]
last long yeah